je vais pas je vais pas me fatiguer
répondre à ces attaques ad hominem
il ya une justice dans notre pays dieu
merci elle est indépendante elle le
montre et j'y tiens là et j'y tiens
beaucoup
et jean renforcerait l'indépendance ce
que vous avez décrit ce sont des
conflits d'intérêts ça se caractérise
pénalement
donc soit ce que vous venez de faire
madame le pen c'est de la diffamation
soit soyez plus précise et aller devant
la justice de notre pays et dans ces cas
là la justice fera son office
comme elle est en train de le faire avec
plusieurs candidats mais je ne vous
laisserai pas diffamer il ya une justice
indépendante
si ce que vous dites est grave et réelle
alors la justice exercera son office